j'ai pris mon vieux trams et je me suis
retrouvé à quelques secondes plus tard
par terre sur la voie sans connaissance
et sans souvenirs et quelques instants
plus tard avec le visage enfants trois
minutes de passage à tabac mais six mois
d'arrêt de travail physiquement j'avais
le nez cassé
j'ai eu une dent qui était cassée qu'il
a fallu arracher et un doigt luxe et
dont je retrouve petit à petit les
usages il y avait un garçon qui était
élève dans une de mes classes qui n'a
pas participé à l'action mais qui a mis
quatre de ses copains sur le coup il a
justifié son attitude par le fait qu'il
a été sanctionné à cause de moi dans
l'établissement lysiens et ses acolytes
ont tous été interpellés
une procédure judiciaire est en cours
alors l'émission est également revenu
sur cette bagarre qui avait fait le buzz
dernièrement c'est au lycée de la
tourelle à sarcelles début octobre un
élève de 1ère avait frappé à coups de
poings son prof de psa cause d'une
casquette les caméras de m6 sont
retournés devant le lycée pour
interroger les élèves et regarder les
réponses des élèves brillants avec le
pull rouge
on y voit un professeur de gym tenter de
maîtriser un élève de première
l'élève lance des coups de poing rageur
personne ne s'interpose
pour quelles raisons en sont ils venus
aux mains à entendre les lycéens
le motif à paraît bien futile d'après ce
que j'ai compris ce qu'eux
on pu lire svp plus certes il a enchaîné
le professeur il n'aurait pas dû rentrer
dans son jeu il aurait juste à sa place
aux mots de petites affiches de gadget
c'est ce que tu fais dans le mille a
frappé comme tous le monde normal alors
la question se pose est-ce que prof en
2002 900 mhz un métier dangereux ou pas
c'est la question du jour j'ai d'autres
gène autres voilà je d'autre lario à
vous montrer je vous dis à beaucoup de
jeunes là qui nous regardent un peu de
soi parce que c'est l'été les vacances
vous trouvez que c'est dangereux vous
valérie benaïm visiblement oui on
recueille de plus en plus de témoignages
a auparavant c'est vrai que alors on va
dire que évidemment on est un peu
nostalgique de l'ancien temps mais le
prof était sacralisant c'est une
profession qu'on respecte est
particulièrement et compris les parents
d'ailleurs parce que on a aussi des
témoignages de professeurs qui qui
disent c'est pas tant les enfants que
parfois les parents qui viennent
eux-mêmes dire je comprends pas je veux
comme je veux que vous me rendiez des
comptes que vous m'expliquer pourquoi
vous avez donné une telle forme d'atout
matin justement ce que vous dites c'est
qu'on l'a vu hier y aller les agressions
d'élèves envers leurs profs mais il ya
également des parents qui s'en prennent
aux professeurs ça donne des scènes
assez surréaliste regarder cette mère de
famille qui menace une prof tout en
sachant qu'elle est filmée regarder
parfois le mauvais exemple vient des
parents tout aussi violents comme ce
mois ci à agde près de béziers ou
l'institutrice est agressée
des menaces de mort aussi je te crève à
chaque fois les personnes sont
interpellées et mises en examen mais le
traumatisme des enseignants reste alors
mais juste un moyen 55% des agressions
sur les profs sont commises par des
parents d'élèves
on ne le sait pas assez serre c'est plus
de la moitié et ses parents d'élèves qui
agressent les profs en fait sont les
élèves qui agressait les profs da 30 ans
c'est à dire que yahia voilà maintenant
ils sont grands et ça se transmet de 2
mais si c'est alors après il faut il
faut il faut raison garder c'est que
c'est une minorité aussi c'est parti sur
dans les biens la voiture de l'envol
hills professeur il n'y a plus aucun
respect total pourquoi parce qu'il n'y a
plus aucune sanction pardon de le dire
mais c'est avec un pays qui n'a plus
d'ordre belga plus de sanctions du tout
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on l'a vu la
cantonade quelqu'un dans la rue sur la
police il est relâché tout de suite et
quand c'est dans les écoles comme ça et
bien qu'est ce qui se passe si par
hasard
yahia il ya un peu d'autorité une gifle
ou quoi tout de suite ça passe ça passe
là la presse le pass est ok au scandale
parce qu'on arrive entourant maltraités
tu veux quand même pas qu'on mette des
baffes aux gamins adorent excuse-moi
quelques-unes mais devant venir marche
mais pour en revenir à l'autorité moi je
suis désolé ça me choque ce que je vois
que ce professeur de se battre parce
qu'elle demandait un élève dans le veine
casquette mais on est bien sûr on est où
vous alors où sa griffe sur niveau on
peut mettre des gifles des enfants de
temps en temps et par on n'est pas des
plus jeunes d'entre eux n'est pas
présent évoqué d'autorité s'ils
voulaient les sanctions fédérant c'est
la peur du professeur et la peur de la
police par itunes est ce que tu veux le
professeur ici
l'héritage pourra la prendre non mais
magie sur ici vous pouvez pas dire ça
c'est interdit
jean-michel internes et les beaux jours
des excuses yahia interdite quand
j'étais à l'école on se connaît une
barbara par le prof
on rentrait chez soi disant pourvu que
mon personnage pas que j'ai pris mon
pape sur la reprenait une deuxième
rencontre à la maison parce qu'on a
[ __ ] un aveu d'échec
c'est pas un aveu d'échec aujourd'hui il
veut faire l'avocat du diable a tué à
plein de gens qui vont dire ça c'est les
paroles de vieux cons qui dit ça
évidemment tout ça je dis la vérité
bêtise tu te grain du papier que je
teste en banlieue du badakhshan amis
là-bas gâteau pour votre mère est prof
ma maman est prof de français oui dans
un collège alors pas du tout dans une
zone à risque ou dans une zone difficile
elle est l épreuve de français dans un
collège en creuse donc c'est plutôt à
ses cadres même si évident évidemment il
ya des problèmes elle a répondu oui elle
à cette question je vais poser
directement et en fait le métier de prof
la fonction en tout cas de professeurs
souffrent de plus en plus d'un manque de
considération d'un manque de respect de
la part de toutes les instances de des
parents des enfants du directeur d
établissement et c est ce qu elle m'a
aussi pointé du doigt elle sait que de
plus en plus surtout la en 2019
ils ont affaire à ce qui s'appelle les
enfants rois on peut plus courir sur l'
app auquel on ne peut plus rien dire ne
peut plus les frustrés on ne peut pas
leur couper la parole on ne peut pas les
contredire
parce qu'ils vont se plaindre auprès des
parents et c'est les parents qui après
interviennent derrière et ce à tous dès
lors rien témoignage que voulez vous
montrez pas si vous l'avez vu c'est
celui d'hervé caudron c'est un
professeur qui a témoigné sur lci depuis
son lit d'hôpital
le visage encore marqué par une
agression regardes et tu as réussi à
l'est où c'est là qu'est ce que j'ai
fait je les attrape et où les nous et je
les ai mis dehors de l'atelier jeu
et vers celui qui était juste devant je
vais devant lui avec mes lunettes et
tous sains et muette
je vais devant lui pas accroché voilà à
s'accrocher à ça sert mans gérant temps
j'ai entendu comme un bruit biscotte
jamais j'aurais pensé qu'un élève puisse
mon foot à coup hier c'est aberrant
leader mondial mais c'est pas seulement
le problème de la violence pure comme on
voit là le témoignage est
particulièrement terrifiant terrifiant
c'est qu'on demande à l'école de régler
tous les problèmes posés par la société
n'arrive pas à régler
donc tous les réserves sur l'école des
gosses qui sont pas éduqués c'est
l'école qui doit les éduquer la société
arrive pas éduquer les gamins l'école
doit s'en charger ben non on n'est pas
la risoul aura pour ça les profs ils
sont là pour enseigner on leur demande
de faire tout le reste mais ça donne ça
l'autre que tirer la mode époque où les
élèves avaient peur des professeurs
étaient des nordmann aujourd'hui les
professeurs ont perdu en péril dévoilé
la zone pour aider les élèves avaient
tort des professionnels seront avec part
on leur serre
moi j'en ai pas qu'on dise partout c'est
tout blanc ou tout noir
art et essai rien apporté à dire non
mais pas du tout arrêté il ya des ja
d'île ya aussi voilà je vous dis bien
sûr qu'il ya des professeurs voilà qui
attire beaucoup de difficultés mais
c'est pas la majorité des élèves qui
sont comme ça non pareil pour les rosés
soeur qui voit là et c'est tout le monde
va tout le monde n'est pas des plus tôt
nous n'est pas tout blanc cyril tous les
mois il soudainement vous bénévoles
d'abord professeur a pris 7 par métier
dangereux si dense et très inquiétant
policiers et policières mémoire il vient
qui a déclaré bien nommé il ya des faits
divers il ya demandé des événements
dramatiques qui sont des cas isolés moi
je fais confiance moi j'ai des enfants
qui sont encore au lycée
je fais confiance aux profs et j'espère
j'espère ne pas qu elle veut pas penser
que ce soir était dangereux voilà des
cas c'est un
créée dans le reportage tacite est
tellement compliqué que des
entraînements sont organisées à
destination du personnel scolaire
le but apprendre aux professeurs et aux
éducateurs à bien réagir en cas de
dispute avec des élèves parce que le
problème c'est que vous pouvez pas agir
par la force et vous pouvez pas non plus
et voilà m mounier vous défendre donc
c'est compliqué au regard du hajjah par
la force comme ici la scène reproduit
l'intrusion d'une personne qui n'est pas
élèves dans l'établissement
tu ne touches pas si c'est moi il ya
montreuil à kevin a signé clément
s'interposer ou raisonnée j'ai par
contre est souvent tout va très vite des
ghettos
la femme et blessé à terre l'homme armé
d'un couteau entre sans être suivis
libre de ses mouvements
on se rattrape chaud
toi tu vois les gendarmes tu n'en
perdent pas une miette on a fait de ce
carton lice voilà alors voyez ça aura
donc on a on apprend aux professeurs la
force n'est pas une solution parce que
vous tombez sur des gamins d'un mètre 90
s'est passé pas le gamin de 8 ans tu vas
lui mettre une petite claque que tu vas
te faire des montées en retour c'est pas
2 c pas la solution non plus alors
mémoire et soeurs à maîtriser un enfant
est mort on va le sondage si on fait un
métier dangereux moins 78 personnes non
afin de consentir à dean pour conclure
non mais bien sûr c'est un métier
dangereux et moi je comprends leur leur
burn-out leur dépression leur suicide
aujourd'hui il ya plein de profs qui se
suicide et moi je pense que le problème
ça a été les réformes successives où on
les a maltraité ou on les a mal aimé on
les a pas considérer où ils sont sous
payés on leur met 35 élèves dans dans la
même classe on en a rien à [ __ ] et et
franchement moi je trouve que c'est une
honte et je pense qu'à partir du moment
l'éducation va pas dans un pays où le
pays peut pas aller en fait et ça
explique tout ça explique la police
explique l'abbé bouillir ce sujet